on a tout vécu et des trahisons
certaines par la faute du système
d'autre part la faute de leurs familles
par la faute d'un inconnu
y'a rien qui me fait plus flipper que
d'entendre des mecs
[Musique]
on est des hommes nous avons bâti ce
pays donoma viril et maintenant elles
veulent qu'on renonce au pouvoir sans
broncher et qu'on le donne à des
personnes qui sont incapables et indigne
de l'exercer
elles devront passer sur mon corps
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi ce qu'on fait et ben genre
grand nettoyage des rues
elle a de la chance que je la dérange
pas j'ai hâte de voir cela implique une
bande de féministes veut saboter vos
meetings
il faut plus de protection
[Musique]
on lui offrira une place à la morgue
avant la fin de la journée
personne fera justice pour nous donc il
faut qu'on s'en charge tout seul vous la
connaissez mais moi vous connaissez pas
cette violence a pas forcément vous
retombez sur jours
types sont des tueurs professionnels ils
veulent pas pour l'heure un conseil les
mecs soyez sages
ouah
oui